les platanes du boulevard béranger et le
risque de les perdre n'aura pas réussi à
enterrer définitivement le projet de la
seconde ligne de tramway à tours les 22
maires de la métropole viennent de
ressortir des cartons l'ancien tracé par
le boulevard jean royer une solution qui
ferait l'unanimité notamment chez les
trois maires concernés par l'arrivée de
ce moyen de transport structurants du
côté des commerçants l'entousiasme n'est
pas le même romain delville
jean royer aura finalement son tramway
ainsi on a décidé hier soir à
l'unanimité la conférence des maires de
la métropole vous voyez n'est pas un
choix par défaut cl c'est le choix qui
se fait puisqu'il ya tellement de
contraintes à bérenger passons pas royer
pour faire cette deuxième ligne parce
que derrière il faudra faire la
troisième ligne st-pierre ainsi sur
place ce matin ce n'est pas la joie chez
des commerçants au petit bistrot on se
relève à peine d'un contexte défavorable
après deux ans de kovy des de
restriction en tout genre la gérante ne
vois pas l'intérêt de faire passer un
tramway sur ce boulevard fait craint que
son établissement de survie vos travaux
malheureusement la trame s'y passe ici
ça va être la grosse catastrophe pour
les commerçants pour rapporte ou quoi
pour les travaux enfin voilà pour nous
c'est fini c'est sûr un peu plus loin
même son de cloche chez le réparateur de
pare brise à l'idée que la chaussée soit
coupée pendant les travaux du tramway le
responsable du centre est bouleversé
pendant les travaux mao fera rien du
tout la rapide pir comme d'habitude
hélas
sans commentaire après
c'est connu on puisse on le fait partie
d'une succursale on a deux sans surprise
sur tours nord assure chambray-lès-tours
ci va se passer parce qu'ils vont fermer
le centre
avec ce projet remise à plat il va
falloir relancer de nouvelles études sur
le boulevard jean royer environ 2
millions d'euros et se tourner vers les
banques le projet est réévalué à hauteur
de 570 millions d'euros c'est urgent de
le faire maintenant puisque ballet tout
comme vous le savez risque d'augmenter
donc il faut absolument qu'on signe ses
emprunts notamment auprès de la banque
européenne d'investissement très
rapidement puisque le projet est tout à
fait cohérent c'est une ligne complète
et ça c'était absolument nécessaire
à l'origine la ligne b du tramway devait
sortir de terre en 2025 il y aura la
métropole frederico gil évoquer
l'horizon 2030